do not take the contents of this video
as an endorsement of the bbc in its
current state the news arm of the bbc
continues to defend its recent history
of anti-trans articles ignoring the
damage to the trans community it is
facilitating in a pinned comment below
you'll find links to my original video
on the issue two follow-up videos from
the youtuber sean and a recent protest
speech from laura kate dale
thank you now on with the video
doctor who has had at this point 15
canonical doctors possibly a lot more
depending on how you choose to count
them or how
future events in upcoming episodes pan
out but
we do seem to have a limited pool of
ones that we can have reappear
or do we
[Music]
so
this is a question that i've had asked
of me in comments and i think live
streams once or twice and i never really
felt the need to tackle it because
i i my own answer is honestly pretty
straightforward
and i'll try and be as fair as i can
when addressing the topic but i'll also
i'll tip my hand up front on the
question of should we
cast new actors to play previous doctors
if the previous actor is
no longer with us and unable to take on
the part
no no we shouldn't thank you and good
night except i've been thinking about it
more and part of the reason i was a bit
dismissive on it was because
i didn't think it was exceptionally
likely yes granted technically we have
had this happen one time already and i
will deal with that in a little bit why
i was more or less okay with that at the
time it happened
but this
this has come back up in my mind because
recently big finish
uh who i hadn't actually fully
appreciated just how many characters
they're getting um voice doubles for
these days but this landed on my radar
because of the announcement that michael
trout and one of patrick trouten's sons
patrick trout and being the second
doctor is going to voice the second
doctor in an upcoming big finish audio
now that audio in and of itself i look
at that cast and i'm already like oh my
gosh really because out of all the
returning characters and there's a lot
of returning characters in this planned
audio drama
the only one who's the original actor is
frasier hines who played jamie mccrimmon
they have
um
imitation and voices for the second
doctor the third doctor liz shaw and the
brigadier
it's
getting out of hand now it's not as if
doctor who um the show proper takes a
ton of cues from big finish and by and
large i'm okay with that i tend to feel
like especially lately big finish has
usually been more solid and they
definitely do some great stuff but i
like that what they do
is not
like some kind of direct funnel or feed
into what the show proper does i like
them kind of being their own thing that
is connected it's not completely
separate but
i like them not
i like it not becoming the snake that
eats its own tail where like one feeds
into the other and then back into the
other and it becomes a feedback loop
between the two uh different divisions
that are handling doctor who material
right now
but that having been said
what worries me is with more hardcore
fans at least because let's be honest
the more casual fans of doctor who don't
get into big finish
partly because it's a more niche medium
in the first place being on audio drama
as opposed to television uh and two it's
uh cost prohibitive like you gotta be
devoted to doctor who to get into big
finish in any heavy dose it's expensive
to keep up with
so
it really is only an issue for the
hardcore fans but it still worries me
the idea that this is becoming
increasingly normalized amongst the most
diehard fans of doctor who
because if it gets normalized there
it could potentially
be felt by the people running the show
at this point now or at some point in
the future that well fans seem to have
accepted it in that medium
let's try it with tv
so again like i know they've done it
once before i said i'd get to it we'll
get back to it
but
on the one hand
i understand the appeal and it is a very
fan driven appeal that we would like
to see
old doctors come back if not in a
massive highlighted role at least in
some capacity i mean that was one of the
better moments in the day of the doctor
when we had like these isolated clips
obviously all brought together through
editing as opposed to any of these
people actually being in the same room
and that final shot was not the best
composited thing in the world but there
was a thrill
at seeing all of the at the time
canonical doctors appearing
on the screen together that was really
cool i get the pop that fans get from
that
but
here's
my problems with this
firstly as a creator and as someone who
has in the past had acting ambitions
wouldn't mind getting into more voice
work than i have so far to be honest but
like as someone who who
has
a draw
towards acting
the idea that
the original versions
are going to be superseded by
new actors in the part
makes me a little bit uncomfortable now
that doesn't usually bother me when
we're doing like a full reboot of
something because you're saying flat out
look everybody's different everybody's
new like don't worry about it you're
either gonna you're either gonna accept
that everybody in this is recast because
it's a remake or reboot or whatever or
you're just not going to watch it fine
but having it happen
within
the continuing continuity in which
these characters these versions of the
doctor have already been performed by
their original actors
i don't it feels off to me it feels
callous
about their contributions that
the show might start treating them as
replaceable
and that's one of the very cool things
about doctor who is that the character
remains
but the because of the mechanism that is
regeneration each new actor
is not inherently replacing who came
before because the show flat out
acknowledges this is the same person but
also not
it's in narrative that it's not exactly
the same person which allows each new
actor to do their own thing and to not
be beholden to what came before and it
doesn't feel inherently disrespectful to
previous incarnations of this character
played by other actors
but to bring in somebody new even if
they're great either
as um as an imitation of or as a
reinterpretation of some of these old
versions of the doctor
it just feels uh
to me and again i don't worry so much
about big finish doing it like i don't
ever plan to listen to any of the
stories where big finish has done that
it doesn't bother me so much that they
do it there because again that's more
for the niche fans but it's that
normalizing of it
that worries me because
if it becomes
normal
in
maine
tv show episodes of doctor who
to just cast a look alike
who can do an impression
an actor who you're already hamstringing
because they have to be believable as
the previous version of this character
and they're not going to be able to
completely do their own thing with it
which is its own kind of okay whatever
but
the whole concept just gives me unease
at every level it makes me feel bad for
the original performers because it it
belittles their unique contributions and
saying well we can get other people to
do this same thing
i know that's not the intentional
message but it is an underlying
quality that happens with this um and
look i know in various shows sometimes
characters get recast without
regeneration being a thing and but
usually there's extenuating
circumstances around that
whereas here these characters have been
closed off so
there's that there's that sort of
diminishing of the importance of the
original actor there's the hamstring of
any new actor you cast where they're
going to be stuck just doing an
impression and aren't truly going to be
able to build their own character i'm
sure there are plenty of actors who
would be happy for the work regardless
but again it's kind of undermining what
they might potentially bring to the part
as an actor the entire exercise is the
exact kind of thing that i worry about
doctor who's future in general which is
this is the same reason why i say i do
not want as much as i
hate the timeless child and i hate it i
do not want russell t davies to waste a
single minute
of his time taking over doctor who again
wants chimney leaves
on retconning or even explaining it
it didn't work
move on i think where so many
long-running things happen you see this
in comic books a lot it's part of why
they do full continuity reboots all the
dang time well dc does them a lot and
marvel has unfortunately started to dip
into some of this as well
but the reason they do all these resets
is because over time the stories become
too insular
too hung up on pre-existing knowledge
and that's fine to a point but when it's
been running for we're coming up on the
60th year anniversary of doctor who next
year
getting too hung up especially in
narrative like it's one thing to have
easter eggs it's one thing to have a
certain species of alien who hasn't been
seen in a while come back to me nods to
the past work best
when they still work within narrative
even if you do not know or have not seen
where it comes from it still works now
as it's being used
but the reason i don't want things like
the timeless child retconned is because
it just means that the show isn't moving
forward it's looking back
and that is how these
shows these long-running franchises
become overly obsessed with their own
history and start truly spinning their
wheels i have not been a big fan of
chibnall's era but what i will give it
credit for is that he did try to move
things forward in new directions and try
new things i don't feel like most of
them worked but i appreciate the effort
more than i would someone who is just
going to come in and recycle and rehash
and bring back all this old stuff for no
apparent reason other than
just fan wanking
for lack of a
less degenerate way of saying it
so
that entire mentality
the idea of oh bring back the old stuff
well we can't the actors are and like i
don't have a problem with old doctors
returning from multi-doctor stories but
the idea of okay well let's bring back
some more stuff well we can't bring that
back the actors aren't with us anymore i
don't care get somebody new
that that is a level of
looking back and dwelling on the past
that i don't think is healthy for any
franchise and i think we've been very
lucky with doctor who that thanks to the
refreshing concept that is regeneration
it has not fallen victim to the same
degree of i'm not gonna say it's immune
to it but it hasn't fallen victim to the
same degree of it as most franchises
that have been actively ongoing for as
long as doctor who has
so
there's that and at this point i suppose
i should come back to what i said i was
gonna set aside which is david bradley
playing the first doctor
now
i don't
love
uh twice upon a time there are parts of
it i like there are aspects that i like
and he does a perfectly fine job in the
role
as far as these things go playing the
first doctor but i still don't really
like it
the reason i gave that one a pass
is
because of the specific circumstances
around it
which
is david bradley had played
not the first doctor
but the actor
william hartnell
in the tv movie an adventure in space
and time
and
to me
his appearing as the first doctor felt
far more like an extension
of that
than an attempt to replace
william hartnell and actually it's worth
bringing up with william hartnell david
bradley isn't even the first replacement
first doctor we've had because during
the five doctor's special william
hartnell had already passed away and so
they had a new actor there they brought
in richard herndell to play the first
doctor i'll be honest i don't really
like it there either
now
that one's more of a looking at the past
for me because i wasn't watching doctor
who back then
but
they've done it
twice
now both times with the first doctor i
don't love it either time
i kind of let it pass for the five
doctors as honestly
it was a little bit of an experiment and
classic era didn't do that again and as
i as i said
i let david bradley pass because it felt
like an extension of a different doctor
who related project that he did where he
was excellent and it felt more like a
natural extension of that than just
trying to go okay this is now the first
doctor
but that might just me be me giving a
pass to an actor i liked
and it's association with the movie
project that i like if i was going gonna
be stricter about it i'd be harsher on
that as well but i'd be lying if i said
i didn't feel like that was
okay
but not because the general idea of
recasting the doctors with new actors is
okay at least i don't feel that it is
and the only reason i did there was it
had super specific circumstances to it
and look i know
for a lot of long-running fans of doctor
who and those of us whether we were
alive back during when classic aired or
have
gone back and revisited and taken it in
after falling in love with knew who or
whatever
there's a certain amount of sadness
in not getting new
tv adventures
for
a lot of these doctors
i do get that
that is a bummer
but
trying to
force the creation of the next best
thing
i don't think that gives us what we're
missing
i think it
deludes what we have
now
there's certainly plenty of ways to get
additional adventures
comic books
novels
if they're well written and in the
correct characterization those
can work as a substitute and again while
i'm not gonna listen to the big finish
stuff where they have uh sound of likes
if that's where you want to go fine
i'm still a little bit
on it fine
don't carry it over to tv
i i've said in general terms on various
points there are some things that are
neat things
that doctor who in mediums aside from tv
has done
it has gone ridiculous
and wacky and meta and head trippy in
things like novels comics uh and big
finish in ways that the tv show hasn't
and i think in many cases the tv show
shouldn't
because the tv show is what everything
else takes its cues from and i'm not
saying this that the tv show should be
safe
but i'm saying that these other mediums
they can do something experimental
and whether it does or doesn't work it
doesn't have to spread beyond that
specific medium
because
not everything is gonna pull from the
comics the novels or if they do they're
gonna pick and choose
the show is the main canon
when it's on the show
that sets the standard
that becomes what doctor who is
the rest
i'm not saying it's not canon but you
can take it or leave it as you want
be careful what you do with the show
and i'm personally
going to continue to argue against
the idea of casting new actors
to play
older versions
of the doctor
i really don't want it
i wish we could have had
more from some of these doctors i really
do some of the ones that are still with
us you want to bring them in i will
happily see what you're going to do with
them
but
the ones that are gone
let their legacy be their legacy
don't
turn it into something else
but maybe i'm just a killjoy
maybe it is a neat idea and i just can't
get on board with it it's possible
i can be a grumpy bastard
but whatever your thoughts are on this
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
if you want to support what i do i have
a patreon also a link in the description
any amount of support helps and there's
also links to my other projects as well
things like twitch and tick tock etc etc
etc uh don't worry too much about it
though because my friends at the end of
the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
thanks for sticking around into the
credits none of this would have been
possible without my patreon supporters
in particular i want to thank robin
powell tracy scrabbit vincent paul
partolucci robin moore jayla gourle and
bookworm
thanks for keeping this going and to
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]